[Musique]
jadot quoi trouver que pour faire partir
la fusée il suffisait de la laisser
tomber
alors les shadoks porte c'est décidé
[Musique]
heureusement qu'ils partent d'ailleurs
car depuis le temps qu'on en parlait
nous commencions à nous impatienter et
bien non il ne partait pas encore cette
fois là
[Musique]
figurez vous que tout à coup les shadoks
et leurs ustensiles surpris d'étranges
convulsions il se tordait se déformer
puis maigri et des gourdes et et à la
fin disparaissait il avait attrapé la
maladie
c'était
la maladie cosmique qui se promenait
dans les espaces interstellaires et
surtout quand il y avait des choses qui
ne lui plaisaient pas ou qui la gênait l
arrivée et n'entendait plus parler
or les shadows justement ça ne lui
plaisait pas tellement des animaux aussi
mal en pis des 10es nous n'avons pas eu
de fabriquer des choses comme ça elle
n'allait tout de même pas perdre son
temps elle a surveillé des bêtises
pareilles alors les malheureuses bêtes
terrassé par le terrible fléau
disparaissaient les unes après les
autres
bientôt il n'y en aurait plus la fin des
shadows peut-être avait sonné
[Musique]